[Musica]
buongiorno
buongiorno a tutti
grazie buongiorno a tutti buongiorno
presidente adolfo guzzini
se siete a roma e vi piace guardare il
bello del novecento italiano
avrete sicuramente visto la facciata del
palazzo della civiltà italiana all'eur
in cima a quella facciata c'è una
scritta meravigliosa che siccome
riassume volti molti mestieri che gli
italiani nel fatto mi sono scritto di
lei vi prometto che l'unica cosa che
leggo oggi un popolo di poeti di artisti
di eroi di santi di pensatori di
scienziati di navigatori di
trasmigratori bene tolto forse i santi
per i quali c'è sempre tempo per oro
uno di questi è adolfo guzzini un uomo
che ha cambiato il modo in cui in italia
si fa impresa e si fa e si racconta la
bellezza italiana ultimo di sei fratelli
in un'epoca negli anni cinquanta in cui
diciamo che i primogeniti aveva uno
spazio particolare specie se i
primogeniti maschi
eppure sempre insieme con i suoi
fratelli quindi questa avventura che è
nata in modo familiare e che poi però
lui ha apportato sempre avanti in questi
anni ha fatto illuminazione innanzitutto
evidentemente bellezza design e tutte
queste cose insieme si chiamano appunto
i cussini per cui è particolarmente un
onore un privilegio per me è chiederti
qualche cosa presidente l'ha ricordato
poco fai ancora pertile tu hai vinto
quest'anno il premio compasso d'oro alla
carriera tra le altre cose c'è il premio
leonardo con premio importante poi c'è
una lunga lista di riconoscimenti se
dovessi leggervi avremo finito il tempo
che il telex ci concede e quindi volevo
soltanto iniziare con te da un ricordo
come molte buone idee guzzini nasce in
un garage in che senso
esattamente dunque innanzitutto sei
fratelli e tutti i più grandi di me che
sono stati dei grandissimi e formatori
per me sostanzialmente sono loro che
hanno messo il seme e dei concetti e
strumenti innovativi
all'epoca per il settore dell'industria
manifatturiera che poi un artigianato e
parliamo della fratelli guzzini che
nasce nel
nemmeno 112 dal non enrico dalla mio
padre 2g e poi dai miei fratelli più
grandi che chiaramente hanno sviluppato
ampiamente questa realtà i fratelli
essendo una famiglia numerosa dice
guarda non c'è posto per tutti bisogna
che facciamo qualcos'altro e proposero
di rifare apre che illuminazione davvero
chiaramente ho già avendo utilizzato i
designer gli architetti prima di roma
poi i tedeschi poi di milano e del mondo
oggi è la fratelli guzzini e stata
pertanto antesignana a livello regionale
e nazionale facendo e partecipando allo
sviluppo del made in italy nel moto
l'illuminazione sa esattamente ha avuto
lo stesso percorso e successivamente
addirittura arrivare a trainare in
termini dimensionali in termini di
complessità generale ma ricordando che
questa seconda azienda come la prima
nasce da un garage nel centro storico da
città di recanati ma comunque una città
dove il bello dove la bellezza dove la
cultura dove i leopardi lotto beniamino
gene di grande tenore e tantissimi
minori e noi siamo abbiamo tante
antenati losing ora pero sanzio rossini
siamo marchigiani ecco questo è un seme
importante è che voglia di fare voglia
di operare più che di non apparire
sostanzialmente e tra questi
protagonisti del passato che adesso tu
hai citato e anche del presente
metterei i designer che hanno
collaborato e lavorato con guzzino in
questi anni mi viene in mente da renzo
piano a gae aulenti
mi viene in mente da gio ponti a tanti
altri uno di questi su uno di questi
vorrei puntare e del caso di dirlo è su
queste minuti che abbiamo insieme con
adolfo guzzini la luce e il riflettore
lo metterei se permetti su luigi massoni
assurde vi ha dato qualche cosa vi ha
lasciato qualche matita qualche tratto
di matita la nostra rete non solo e non
solo mi auguro e non solo assolutamente
cioè tra i tanti design architetti che
hanno collaborato con noi sono veramente
tanti i primi italiani poi giapponesi
anche o tedeschi
o americani oggi inglese eccetera e cioè
perché chiaramente bisogna acquisire
cultura internazionale soprattutto per
noi che operiamo nel settore
dell'architettura architettura di
qualità e nel servizio dell'italia nei
beni culturali nelle grandi
infrastrutture aeroportuali e
quant'altro veni alla illuminazione
delle città diciamo che siamo stati un
azienda che ha percorso pre pre corso
dei tempi e degli sviluppi
dell'innovazione luigi mazzone è stato
un architetto sardo di origine che era
direttore artistico della boffi cucine
che i miei fratelli più grandi hanno
conosciuto attraverso un nostro
distributore è un fornitore di materia
prima di acrilico dell'asia inglese
la famiglia dell'anno di milano è
chiaramente conoscendola avendo visto
quello che questo signore faceva già
alla tenera età dei 27 28 anni due
riviste una di queste era forme che
parlava solo di design è una persona che
aveva una mano felicissima e che ha
fatto veramente tanto per il made in
italy che poi si è diffuso nel mondo
meno conosciuto forse di tanti altri
rispetto a quello che è la realtà ma un
uomo che chiaramente dove mettere la
mano si realizzava un prodotto di
estrema qualità e via federico portarono
nelle marche e iniziò a lavorare col
nostro gruppo industriale prima con la
fratelli guzzini successivamente con
l'illuminazione e dove il chiaramente ho
cercato a piene mani in cui i miei
fratelli e lavoravano sono stati loro
coloro che hanno anche pensato di fare
questo sviluppo ha dato veramente tanto
chiedendogli anche di collaborare
strettamente in termini di coordinamento
di immagine aziendale di no non solo
pertanto prodotto dei saldi prodotto ma
chiaramente di comunicazione di public e
relazioni pubbliche e quant'altro perché
dobbiamo attingere da milano e attingeva
modà milano la cultura del design che
già attraverso la domus era largamente
diffuse per tentare verso gio ponti
ecco questo è avvenuta di massoni negli
anni 62 64 ha fatto sì poiché con nei
fratelli in particolare raimondo che era
il fratello più grande che avevano
sviluppato il processo della
comunicazione e della
commercializzazione di prodotti prima in
italia poi alcuni paesi esteri e
l'abbiamo presentata da franco moschini
chiare il presidente della poltrona
il quale stava presentando la dezza di
gio ponti siamo seduti sopra in questo
esatto e qui siamo in uno dei bellissimi
prodotti marchigiani infatti a mano è
chiaramente un vanto dell'italia che
oggi è in giro per il modo comunque
l'abbiamo presentato dicendo riguarda
questo è un questo architetto sta
facendo queste cose con bossi con noi
confratelli consigli pertanto penso che
devi sostanzialmente prenderne atto
conoscerlo e frequentarlo poi da lui
siamo passati a pazzini che ha sempre il
gruppo gabrielli alla farfisa grande
industria degli strumenti musicali né
zona b e di ancona è così e poi anche
l'occasione di un grande albergo che
risalta che stia nei 300 camere 600
posti detto abbiamo avuto modo di
portare questo seme che avevamo già
portato nuovi negli anni 50 il mio
fratellino a 50 50 sul territorio e far
capire l'importanza del brand identity
tante si realizzò un seminario negli
anni 68 in cui si fece un convegno con
massoni con una società di comunicazione
che era la nostra agenzia chiaramente
una dichiarazione e una di
commercializzazione e
internazionalizzazione
in prima fila c'era il grande vittorio
merloni con il suo direttore
intanto c'è chi a capire comprendere
eccetera che all'epoca loro erano nel
primo livello di design di
industrializzazione sostegno
socializzavano fatta ma non c'è una
cultura e rame più metalmeccanica che di
design eco pertanto diciamo questo
lavoro fatto nelle marche veramente è
stato quello che ci ha portato essere
sempre inclusivi e non esclusivi cioè
non essere gelosi delle nostre
conoscenze e competenze
abbiamo sempre voluto guardare avanti
fare relazioni cercare di capire conosce
il mondo e pertanto utilizzare tutte le
leve possibili per migliorare il nostro
essere italiani
erano gli anni allegri arrembanti
possiamo dire all'inizio anche affamati
del boom italiano è però siamo già
arrivati verso la città degli anni
sessanta e non piu tardi del 1973
succede una cosa come tutte le storie
che hanno i loro momenti difficili
succede una cosa che per altre aziende
della illuminazione poteva e forse è
stata s poteva essere forse è stata una
catastrofe si chiama crisi petrolifera
crisi energetica
ce li ricordiamo le code fuori dai
distributori in italia ma anche il primo
discorso sul risparmio
com'è che avete superato un simile
scoglio passaggio di boa
dunque pur lavorando con le materie
plastiche esattamente però con la
plastica più qualificate che era il
materiale acrilico che aveva una
trasparenza superiore a cristallo pari
al 98 per cento
pertanto materiale che non era plastica
mera si diceva quella volta era un
prodotto guzzini e noi sviluppano con
l'illuminazione una politica
immediatamente di internazionale come
eccezione all'estero vendite creazione
distributori esclusivi
gli agenti in giro per l'europa e
successivamente nel mondo e questo
passaggio ci consente di fare una
jointventure nel 70 per i mercati
dell'est e che è stata una prima
avventura importante per il nostro
gruppo come illuminazione nel 72 la
facemmo in nord america in canada al sul
bordo del no degli stati uniti perché
perché avevamo con massoni sviluppato
dagli riprodotto che veramente erano e
strumenti innovativi che addirittura
parliamo di una cosa semplicissima un
trequarti di sfera che ancora oggi viene
evitato da noi e da un'altra azienda
italiana nostra amica no ma in questo
caso concorrente e per dire qual era la
purezza e l'innovazione minima no con le
applicazioni di materiali per poter
consumare meno energia e quant'altro
comunque questa queste riprodotto quelle
alcune altre ovviamente ci hanno
consentito di poter lanciare sul mercato
internazionale anche sul mercato chiuso
dell'est europeo e vendere e
sostanzialmente non lampade contro
patate perché dalla jugoslavia l'epoca
mercato
chiuso con la russia che dominava tutti
i paesi dell'est e chiaramente il
clearing verde si vendeva incline in
verde e questo faceva sì che non c'erano
prodotti offerti per poter godere di
queste novità di queste bellezze e
allora gli stadi dividevano no quello
che si poteva esportare da quello che si
poteva si doveva importare e da lì
nacque una diffusione del marchio su
tutti i mercati dell'est che ancora oggi
che oggi ci dà delle ottime degli ottimi
ritorni ancora a proposito di patate ti
volevo chiedere di parlarci di semi di
zucca presidente abbiamo parlato poco fa
prima di venire qui perché è una storia
bellissima che riguarda il modo in cui
guzzini ha capito che forse la luce non
era soltanto una questione di estetica
ma è una questione di qualità della vita
l'anno scorso a una montagna di libri
che cortina abbiamo avuto peppe
vessicchio che mettendo la musica il
maestro proprio accanto al vino faceva a
cambiare il sapore e il gusto al vino e
succedeva davvero voi avete capito
qualcosa del genere con la luce mi
piaceva che c'era allora ecco diciamo
questo che come illuminazione crisi del
petrolio e il liceo saltato un passaggio
con la crisi e il petrolio abbiamo
capito quando ho avuto la possiedi
conoscere bene il mondo del settore
degli apparecchi umiliazione
le nuove tendenze veniamo dalla città
gli stati uniti cola illuminazione
architetturale o illuminotecnica e così
chiamata che non era un altro che quei
binari elettrificati fondati creati nel
60 da un'azienda lytle year americana
come che poi applicava lo spot lo
applicava gli incassi a soffitto
questa tecnologia era completamente
diversa dalla nostra tecnologia
utilizzata perché era molto più basata
sulla fisica e cioè su degli elementi
che erano le parabole riflettori a
riflettori che doveva governare il
flusso luminoso da questo passaggio
coraggiosa avuto perché ogni crisi
in ogni caso ci ha comportato una
riduzione di fatturato il 25 per cento
grossomodo e la chiusura poi
dell'investimento fatto in canada ci ha
consentito di capire stop dove stava
andando in modo da cogliere questa
opportunità perché in europa c'erano
soltanto tre industrie tedesche una
inglese che lavoravano in questo
comparto
siamo stati la prima italiana a crearci
prova una cultura veramente alta di che
cosa la luce può fare nell'influenza fra
l'uomo e l'ambiente
la luce è stato un valore ed è un valore
fondamentale non ce ne rendiamo conto
ancora ma noi vediamo oggi a delle
applicazioni che poi magari se vorrà
approfondire con gli avremmo
l'opportunità di permette trasformare in
benessere ogni ambiente nel quale noi
viviamo ma questo attraverso degli studi
scientifici delle ricerche che noi
abbiamo avuto modo di fare con diverse
università o per i beni culturali con
l'istituto italiano di restauro di roma
che da 30 anni collaboriamo proprio per
studiare come le pitture come gli
affreschi come le sculture possono
essere meglio no illuminate parliamo la
dal canova all'ultima cena del
michelangelo alla sala degli scrovegni
dove abbiamo applicato nuove tecnologie
e nuovi materiali e nuove formule con
l'internet of things e che consente di
poter interloquire di poter essere
davanti a queste opere e avere tutte le
informazioni su bluetooth che ogni
visitatore può se lo apre no avere
direttamente davanti a ogni quadro ogni
opera che su cui abbiamo operato ea
volte meglio luce può anche significare
meno luce no ecco diciamo che la cosa io
ritengo molto importante che noi abbiamo
fatto una campagna istituzionale oltre
al prodotto allo sviluppo dei servizi
abbiamo dovuto crearci un mercato
innanzitutto perché non c'era il mercato
illuminotecniche pertanto abbiamo creato
uno staff ed i promotori tecnici che
architetti periti meccanici o ingegneri
di qualità giovani volenterosi e
affamati che in qualche modo aiutasse a
promuovere questi prodotti con le
caratteristiche tecniche quant'altro
ecco fin dall'inizio aveva montato su
una parte importantissima che aveva
cambiato un'azienda artigiana seppur già
con un buon fatturato in un'azienda
industriale di livello internazionale
ma dove la ricerca scientifica dove la
ricerca sulla qualità degli uomini
la formazione degli uomini e la
selezione e creare pertanto il
management e che ci consentisse di poter
avere oggi 22 filiali giro per il mondo
con 1.500 dipendenti per quanto riguarda
la parte illuminazione che va dal
con tre stabilimenti produttivi l'italia
rappresenta il 90 85 per cento in cina
da 13 anni siamo stati gli unici
italiani nel nostro comparto insieme a
due aziende europee nel settore
illuminazione ad avere un altro sito
industriale per seguire tutto il
processo
la parte dell'oceano indiano pacifico e
abbiamo fatto una questione del nord
america
l'anno scorso proprio per poter
approfondire penetrare meglio perché
bisogna essere vicino al mercato oggi il
servizio e il servizio nostro significa
assistere gli architetti assiste
dell'aidia sana capire bene le
performance e che ogni azienda può dare
ci avviciniamo alla conclusione due
ultime domande la prima quando nei 92
avete fatto uno slogan che si intitolava
chi ha rubato la via lattea punto
interrogativo a chi gli riferiva che
allora era un periodo di delle crisi
chiamiamole sociali politiche economiche
del nostro paese troviamo anche mani
pulite dai mani pulite insomma mani
pulite e allora abbiamo avuto abbiamo
illuminato un parco un giardino di
portoghesi lo porto da una della bara
portoghese da una parte dall'altra c'era
un altro fenomeno sostanzialmente noi
abbiamo lanciato uno slogan e
istituzionale di campagna di formazione
informazione con i cugini contro
l'inquinamento luminoso cioè abbiamo
sempre siamo stati molto attenti alla
sostenibilità
pertanto rispetto all'ambiente fino alla
economia circolare essendo stati tra i
promotori del dei consorzi di recupero
dei materiali eccetera
e per quanto riguarda è questo settore è
chiaramente cosa dovevamo dire per
l'inquinamento luminoso
abbiamo fatto delle pagine doppie sui
quotidiani sui settimanali visco chiedo
scusa pagine nere con sottoscritto i
diversi sloga sopra chi ha rubato la
virata e sopra che cosa significava
questo significava che oggi dalle città
non era più possibile vedere la via
lattea gli astrofili ci hanno applaudito
ci hanno seguito ci hanno creato un
movimento a favore nasce nel 92 una
legge proprio sul link metodo meno se
viene messa riferimento la nostra
campagna istituzionale e onestamente
questo ci ha portato poi a creare degli
studi sulla veramente
la luce l'uomo e l'ambiente e creare e
inventare la illuminazione biodinamica
con l'università di troy negli stati
uniti che è il più importante e cerco di
ricerca nel settore dell'illuminazione
abbiamo solo un minuto e ti chiedo di
lasciarci dicendoci in questa epoca
forse un po buia com'è che si continua a
illuminare l'occidente e il mondo com'è
che si continua a fare il progresso
sviluppo diffusione della conoscenza
siamo al tetto d'altra parte dunque
guarda innanzitutto devo dire che
pensiamo un attimo l'italia perché siamo
in una zona di grande pericolo ancora
non voglio essere allarmista io sono un
ottimista ma non possiamo andare avanti
così abbiamo troppi punti deboli
non parlo del ponte ma abbiamo avuto
modo di dibattere no di punt e di quante
problematiche il nostro paese deve
vivere e sopravvivere e anzi sviluppare
dei terremoti
no a tutto quello che l'ambiente
all'energia allegazioni fiscale eccetera
eccetera
con un governo che per ora ci disarmi
rappresenta poco nel senso che non ha
capito non hanno capito che prima di
parlare un ministro deve conoscere bene
è meglio che stia zitto e conoscere bene
le problematiche poter esprimere un
parere competente è una certezza di
diritto
questo è il primo problema l'altro io
sono un grande sono stato un grande
estimatore e ho conosciuto personalmente
marchionne ho avuto possibilità di
incontrarlo più volte è il più
importante uomo che non abbiamo avuto in
italia negli ultimi 40 anni e un uomo
che avuto il coraggio di prendere in
mano un azienda che era quasi in
bancarotta in bancarotta trasformarla in
una potenza internazionale riportando al
paese e in e l'italia strutture di
produzione che erano in polonia per far
sì che rimettendoci in termini economici
per far si che l'economia italiana
potesse riprendere e un uomo che
sollecitava ha creato una struttura
importantissima disegnare chi è
consentito di acquisire la chrysler con
la quale poi ha fatto un lavoro classi
mari faccia nel che noi abbiamo
acquisito in termini di efficienza
produttiva e il concetto è uno solo
motivare i giovani dare spazio ai
giovani
siamo qui
con un palco e non sono qui per
ringraziare voi onestamente perché
questo che state facendo delle cose
estremamente importanti per conoscerci
in un altro momento ma veramente
dobbiamo dare spazi giovani perché il
nostro futuro sono i giovani dove però
il rispetto dei ruoli
la disciplina noi manca disciplinano non
possiamo vivere come stiamo vivendo oggi
perché dobbiamo capire che se noi non
facciamo ricerca sviluppo innovazione e
internazionalizzazione e culturale cioè
essere sprovincializza t è questo il
messaggio che io dico più importante che
dobbiamo portare fuori perché se noi
continuiamo a rimanere a casa e dico
agli studenti quando mi chiamano a fare
delle razioni nell'università o in altri
vostri non possiamo voi che cosa state
facendo quali scioperi state facendo
quali sono i vostri tre primi problemi
che volete far sì che vengano discussi
in maniera cioè ritorniamo sulle piazze
in maniera pacifica ma in maniera
determinata e diamo valore veramente
alle cose che hanno peso e che possono
dare e ridare all'italia la speranza del
futuro per i nostri giovani grazie ad
adolfo guzzini cavaliere del lavoro
grazie grazie a voi
[Applauso]